[Musik]
jetzt hat es geklappt wir wie geht es
dir
mir geht's super die sonne scheint
ausgeschlafen alles gut welt für einige
wehren
letzte woche schon mal so ein bisschen
kontakt gehabt für die letzte folge von
place to be stars & stories
hast du schon mit uns gesprochen und
zwar über ein coming out
ja das ist jetzt schon einige jahre her
ich habe fünf oder ich glaube es müssten
jetzt fünf jahre seien die zeit fliegt
ja nichts desto trotz ist es auch gerade
pride man es deswegen ist es ein
wunderbares thema nochmal darüber zu
sprechen wie war das damals für dich
also damals war das dann auch ich war
jetzt fünf jahre her ich bin da auch in
diesen fünf jahren ist super viel
passiert hast du in deinem leben schon
mal eine situation gehabt wo du aufgrund
von seiner sexualität irgendwie
diskriminiert wurde ist also ich habe
schon erlebt dass wenn man zum beispiel
auf der straße hand in hand geht mit
seiner freundin da komme auf jeden fall
mal blicke ich habe das gefühl dass das
früher mehr war das ein bisschen
abgenommen hat aber es ist auf jeden
fall noch nicht ganz weg also jedes mal
wenn ich meiner freundin wie draußen
unterwegs bin also mit dem moment habe
ich ja keine aber immer wenn das so war
gerade auch im ausland wir waren in
brasilien war das auch komischerweise in
manchen ecken doch schon sehr krass hast
du vielleicht von der 16 jährigen
hamburgerin miriam mitbekommen wie
findest du es dass sie das so über
instagram über social media öffentlich
gemacht hat also ich finde schon dass
wenn man gerade wenn man so
diskriminiert wird weil es ist ja
wirklich wie kann man aufgrund vom
tragen eines kopftuches abgelehnt werden
das ist also ich finde es super dass sie
diese reichweite oder nur zwar darauf
muss auf jeden fall aufmerksam gemacht
werden
ich sehe das ganz genauso und ich finde
das gut wenn darüber gesprochen wird ich
finde das nicht so gut wenn leute dann
tatsächlich einfach vielleicht auch ein
bisschen abgeschreckt sind dadurch und
sich nicht zu wort melden
wir sehen das schon gut wenn man seine
plattform nutzen und darauf aufmerksam
macht gerade damit die leute mal wissen
dieser welt so abgeht wenn so jemand
seine plattform nicht nutzt hat man
davon nicht du bist das ja mehr oder
weniger in deinem job als youtube in
gewöhnt alles mögliche zu teilen und
offen über dinge zu sprechen wie oder
was würdest du jüngeren menschen sagen
die vielleicht nicht tagtäglich so
kommunizieren wie du was würdest du den
mitgeben für ihr coming out also ich
finde dass jeder natürlich seinen
eigenen weg finden muss natürlich kann
nicht jeder die plattform wie ich und
natürlich möchte auch vielleicht einfach
nicht jeder das so aus posen sondern
einfach nur ja ich meine heutzutage ist
es ja auch schon so dass leute das
meistens gar nicht mehr sagen müssen das
ist ja auch schon schön trotzdem haben
wir noch super viel zu tun
was das an gerade was die akzeptanz et
cetera angeht ich glaube schon dass
jeder einfach sein bauchgefühl
entscheiden sollte wenn jemand denkt
okay ich möchte das gerne der und der
freundin erzählen aber mehr leute nicht
dann macht man das so oder weil man
denkt okay ich möchte es einfach
ausleben habe das nicht an die große
glocke hängen macht man das so wenn man
das der familie erzählen will manchen
menschen nicht immer nur den leuten
erzählen bei denen man sich wohlfühlt
das finde ich es ganz wichtig wenn jetzt
tatsächlich noch nicht so oft umgezogen
aber wenn man sich das bei dir so ein
bisschen anguckt dann doch schon mal von
der ein wg dann ins andere land
einige wissen es vielleicht nicht du
hast auch mal mit schering david
zusammen in einer wg wohnt wie war das
denn so das war somit die aufregendste
zeit überhaupt weil wir sind halt gerade
von hamburg das gerade so angefangen sie
hätte sowieso in hamburg gewohnt ich bin
da nur kurz rüber und dann sind wir alle
nach köln gezogen und da bin ich ja
direkt mit ihnen zusammen gezogen weil
wir den anfang so ein bisschen zusammen
machen wollten weil es cool wenn man
jemanden hat mit dem man das zusammen
erleben kann
das war wirklich mit einer der
lustigsten zeit also wir haben ja auch
ich glaube damals unglaublich viele
blogs gedreht in dieser wohnung und war
doch immer zusammen unterwegs ist hat
wirklich so viel spaß gemacht wie ist es
heute
also heute sind wir natürlich noch im
kopf
fakt aber natürlich nicht mehr so viel
wie früher gerade einfach weil ich meine
ich bin nach island gezogen wurde das
glaube ich in berlin das sind halt
gerade wenn man wenn man verschiedene
wege geht ist man halt nicht mehr so oft
zusammen wenn man zusammen wohnt das ist
natürlich ganz klar wir sind noch in
kontakt aber natürlich nicht mehr ganz
so viel wie früher aber wir verstehen
uns nach wie vor richtig gut
es heißt wenn du in berlin bist oder
wenn sie irgendwo mal gesagt hat ich
reiches land bei gesehen hat mich
besucht die hat mich nicht besucht aber
das haben generell nicht so super viele
besucher aber weil ich auch die ganze
zeit selber hin und her gependelt bin
und super viel selbst unterwegs war die
family wahrheit viel da ja nie aber sie
hat mich nicht besucht aber ich auch
nicht haben mich mehrere mich besucht
das war aber einfach weil alle immer in
der weltgeschichte unterwegs sind
ja das stimmt dann wahrscheinlich aber
jetzt wenn du wieder zurück in
deutschland ist ja man hat jetzt viel
mehr zeit man ist ja auch viel näher man
sieht ja nicht mal eben so nach island
das ist ja schon bis wir weiter weg wer
aber jetzt ist man überhaupt nicht mehr
weit voneinander entfernt vielen dank
dass du dir zeit genommen hast ich würde
die letzten worte gerne tier überlassen
vielleicht hast du passend zum kleid
manns oder ein thema was wir gerade
irgendwie am herzen liegt noch eine
kleine message zum abschluss für unsere
community also zum teil monz kann ich
auf jeden fall sage ich meine das ist
jetzt gerade zurzeit seid ihr selbst
entscheidend aus dem bauchgefühl heraus
wenn ihr denkt jetzt der richtige moment
dann erzählt es den leuten mit denen
euch wohl fühlt den leuten den ihr
vertraut und macht das einfach alles so
wie es wollte erzählt entweder menschen
oder erzählt es nicht aber macht das
ganz so wie ich am besten damit fühlt
sehr schön und stehen schon genau sie in
vielen dank dass du dir danken hass und
bis ganz bald hoffentlich wirds ganz
bald
[Musik]